an elite gymnast was kept with has
revealed she was first to alert USA
Gymnastics about sexual abuse
allegations Maggie Nichols came forward
publicly yesterday she accused USA
Gymnastics women's team dr. Larry Nasser
of abuse back in 2015 NASA is now
serving six years in prison after
pleading guilty in a child pornography
case he faces more time for sexual abuse
charges last February 3 gymnast spoke
out for the first time to 60 minutes
about their sexual abuse dr. Jon LaPook
has done extensive reporting on this
story and he's here with the newest
revelations John good morning good
morning Gail since that 60 minutes
reports several Olympic champions have
also come forward including Aly Raisman
mckayla maroney and Gabby Douglas
Maggie Nichols first came forward more
than two years ago but her identity has
not been publicly known until now it's
very very very difficult for her to have
to live with this Jeana Nichols told us
about the pain her daughter Maggie
endured as an alleged victim of sexual
abuse the elite gymnast was the first
athlete to report team dr. Larry Nasser
to USA gymnastics but she's only now
revealing her identity she's finally
decided that she is ready to make this
public and help other victims of Larry
Nasser and maybe make it a safer place
for other athletes in a statement Nikhil
said up until now I was identified as
athlete a I want everyone to know that
he did not do this to athlete a he did
it to maggie Nichols Nichols says the
abuse began in 2012 when she was 15
years old these are girls from 12 to 20
year old girls these are almost all
minors he was allowed as an adult man in
his mid 40s or 50s to do whatever he
wanted to as a physician with no
supervision we never gave any parental
consent nobody was ever in the room he
was allowed to do whatever he wanted to
with his bare hands we couldn't even
stay in that same hotels with her and we
come when she competed for our country
all over the world but then they allowed
a molester to do whatever you wanted to
our daughter as a minor but we were
supposed to trust USA Gymnastics it's
not okay were the other adults that were
there
the Olympic Training Center allowing
this to go on more than 150 women have
now accused Nasser gymnast Jessica
Howard spoke about her experience during
our me to panel she described the trauma
of coming forward I really really
struggle and I don't know if it's ever
gonna go away and I think that's an
important thing for people to understand
that this doesn't just dissipate the
moment you speak up it's almost a moment
that you speak up that you can actually
start to process
Larry Nasser sentencing begins next
Tuesday in a statement to CBS News USA
Gymnastics Ted quote we are focused on
further developing a culture that has
safe sport as a top priority throughout
the organization we can feel mrs.
Nichols anger in her pain we all get
that as parents we know how to protect
our kids from strangers but what do you
do with people that you know well it
turns out when a child is sexually
abused more than 90 percent of the time
it's by somebody who they know so it's
of course can be a difficult
conversation it has to be
age-appropriate but the kids have to
learn what the warning signs are and
just speak up thank you John for your
reporting on this story thank you